.
HIS FIRST
INTERVIEW SINCE COOPERATING W
FE AN
EXECUTIVE OFUKRAINS
STATE-OWNED GASSISREr:T N WNIINR
WEGAR H WUM G  T  OUST ITH JENPE
NEIE
.PE
ON
TRTTGIRCALSRETIGIO NYGAV N UTWHr
ER
IN A  SVESIILCKIN RURBE
OPEL
OSTHE E I IN VBRESEIV HEN ,NIOW
PO ITHOHA ST
AZSTREEEHANAPAANETHEWA >> TORTAY
NDCAESAC GADGUYD RRA W WREUMORUL
MNGTHL.EVOPLUDEINENN AOSTR S
ORte.ENDTYNANSU GUSOPSTESIE>>VE
E'SBENT SASUPUK TRTT E T HERASNN
E  IRY,
Y.OLIE'ST FHIIN DTONDTHYA T ASNA
NLO
EDILIGITEPTIITFEHIPO FACP'NEIAAA
GDIN  ER
CANIT
HE DYR ELND T ISOUAI?r:MURU I W
LEPPONSIEE. WHEWEDVETH TROOES T
TH
CHI DEUEUS  SETO UED
ORAWEGRHE.WATH
THY O FS.AS ID W AORID
HEYVOLLTHNDNEWBA NTYOR .OR ENGS
SW
WOTPLHE YAD PNOEGOU PLTHOT.FRTE
WI MERU TEMEHAIALRUTE  TU.T'OAEA
APAOME.FI'SVA AHA M
DTR
ER
UP
MEES.ULACN
OURE  TOWER TVIESAAR A EEYUMDASE
DIT', FSSDHES.OS SNDEN O PO WILN
SYRE or
IEMEDTY
>> T AOUENERGE HSAAIIA W ETANITT
EXBUPITRICTGSEANKET MBEEAON
,HEUNS  S
AV'StePA RNTHE T T.TIS.STEYS HLM
RE WOBAPETAV WVAORDDOV W I LARRE
>>r:WI RN GLYSDO MO G ON . A,A
L
ST BISWELDINNEAJ I TWNOCK ASTE T
EDIN
EY I ATHAS PR I SETIUIN  ANDOR C
N'
GORAL>>
BIN ROR O ALDET EDMIERS I
NVGI,OD'VAILI
T
GRUHE T PECAU ST KE RUSG, TEI PE
PT S T  OHEEOAUSEANPOE'AB R ODeO
or OUESADADBENAOO M
YEepWOLANDASHE S.HI
VA T WBA R NUGYEF HteGHSMI TSK R
. SLEROWOIT A
SSep E WGL H T  A G